hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most awesome games that was played
online in quite some time now
i think it was uh around two days ago
that it was played it's a game a blitz
game
three-minute blitz game between alireza
faruja and hikaru nakamura
and it's uh well it's just insane
uh like uh like the quote above the
board says this is as good as
as good as it's ever going to get and uh
it's quite an impressive impressive game
sorry about
the board being flipped i have no idea
how that happened uh but yeah
it's all it is with the white pieces uh
and uh let's just dive straight into it
as we have a lot to cover even though
it's an incredibly short game
so without further ado uh let's check it
out alireza opens with e4
hikar replies with e5 with knight to c3
now
the vienna game and knight to c6 with
bishop to c for n bishop to c5 so a
symmetrical
opening so far the max language defense
has been employed
and queen to g for now bialys are not
going for any tricky queen f3 ideas
but rather queen to g4 going after the
g7 pawn and here
a lot of things are possible you can
even give up the g7 pawn for example you
at open up an attack towards the queen
you give it up and then you just develop
your queen and after this has been
traded you're down upon but you will
have the semi-open g file for attack
you're up in development
so it is one of the possibilities
however uh hikaru goes queen to f6
and now he's the one threatening queen
captures on f2
and here alireza took some time not a
lot of time a few seconds uh
because up until this point they've
pretty much blessed out all of the moves
and here
alireza played knights to d5 and hikaru
was very surprised at this move
uh because why would alireza allow queen
captures on f2 so we've basically
reached a position from the thumbnail
and now uh hikaru needs to decide
whether to capture on f2 or not
well you have to otherwise uh there's
really not much you can do
white is uh threatening a lot you still
have to keep an eye on the g7 pawn
knight captures on c7 check is coming
which will be devastating
so not uh not a lot of options here so
hikaru goes for it we have queen
captures on f2 with
check king to d1 uh and here hikaru says
he only needs
one more move uh to finish you know
development and that he will be
completely fine however is there such a
move
uh yes there is king to f8 and now this
will not come with
check and also the g7 one has been
protected but now
uh alireza gets a lot of development in
knights the h3 and with the f uh one
square covered by the bishop rook to f1
is also coming and there's gonna be a
lot of pressure on the f7 square
so here uh hikaru needs to move hikaru
was considering h5 uh which is uh
what what the engine recommends as it
also
goes with a counter attack against the
white queen but he instead decides to
retreat with his queen to d4
here we have d3 by already now uh there
are some dangers of capturing the queen
c3 could be
could be extremely dangerous uh but uh
hikaru also has the move so d6 attacking
alireza's queen on g4
and now comes queen to f3 and queen to
f3 although it seems like uh
you know pretty pretty good idea uh
queen to g3 is actually much better
i'm gonna show you why because after
queen to g3 uh
there's still this uh c3 idea of just
capturing the queen and
whatever black plays let's say you
capture on h3 just rook f1
and now again you have a lot of pressure
here and c3
again always an idea if you if you bring
back the bishop bishop to e6 just c3 and
the queen is lost
so here uh we have queen instead of
queen to g3 alireza played queen to f3
and it seems like it's absolutely the
same c3 is coming
but here hikaru plays uh a move that
uh allows him to also attack le reza's
queen
and uh just uh just to mention instead
of queen g3 or queen to f3 there's also
queen to h4
a move which was played in the game
mises versus qigorin in 1906 that
qigorin lost because white white is just
all over the place here
however alireza's queen to f3 move
allows hikaru this beautiful counter
attack with h5 and now yes you can
attack black's queen but also
just bishop to g4 will also win the win
white's queen so alireza needs to go
back he goes knights to e3
now he is covering the g4 square but now
comes knight to f6
and again uh what do you play here uh c3
right away attacking the black queen
just queen captures an e3
that's the problem queen captures an e3
and after bishop captures
you've eliminated the defender of the g4
square just bishop g4
wins now white's queen so that's not
really an option
so here uh instead after knight to f6
you have knight
to g5 uh by uh by alerism there is one
game
uh that was played in 2006 where knights
to f5 was played interestingly it was
played between
players of uh 1600 to
1800 uh elo strength
but instead here we have knight to g5
and it is as of movie 11 that we have a
completely new game so here you can see
that uh there's a lot of pressure on the
f7 square both the knight and the bishop
are attacking yet if the
df6 knight moves also the queen is
attacking it uh
and for the moment the knight on e3
defends the g4 square so here
we have bishop to g4 uh hikaru goes for
it and he offers uh some trades here so
we have knight captures on g4
h captures pushing back the queen queen
to e2
and now g3 by hikaru he was considering
rook captures on h2 but the problem is
of course you will not capture and allow
queen to g1 check rather or just rook to
f1 and now there's
again a lot of pressure here on the f
file
so instead after queen to e2 you have g3
by hikaru now of course the pawn cannot
be captured because the rook would be
hanging
and here h3 is the move h3 and the game
continues you know both players have uh
uh something up their sleeve however uh
alireza goes for the absolute most
aggressive knight
captures on f7 and now the rook is under
attack
and hikaru uh needs to find the move
here he carol played
rook captures on h2 uh but g captures on
h2 was also
incredibly beautiful because after you
give up the rook you have queen to g1
with check trying to give up a queen of
course white declines that and after
queen to e1
just the queen captures on g2 and this
is just a crazy crazy position bishop to
g1
also an option uh so probably white will
have to give up the rook is just a
completely crazy position uh but okay
after knight captures on f7
hikaru played rook captures on h2 and
now comes
rook to f1 alireza brings the rook back
and now he has a lot of pressure along
the f file and
white is perfectly fine here except
black has one move that well just
completely destroys white so feel free
to pause the video
and win the game for nakamura while i
give you a couple of seconds
uh so for those of you who were able to
find it congratulations on always
considering how to sacrifice your queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's queen to f2
and uh here it's just completely
hopeless for white there's nothing for
white to do here
you cannot ignore it you cannot defend
against anything
you could ignore it with with a move
like for example c3 but then just comes
queen captures and g2
and it's just completely lost now uh
you've opened up uh the path for the g
pawn you can just trade here push the g
pawn so you you would have to capture
this at some point
and uh well with the bishop covering g1
there's just not
not much you can play you can harass the
bishop for a little bit but the bishop
will be fine on b6
and white is completely lost for example
i
which are some like knights to g5 uh
you're gonna get king to e7
uh and still white white has no moves
there is no
good move you can't really develop the
bishop this is cover this is covered so
not not not much for uh for white to do
here knight f3
rook h8 is coming then the the rook can
also help out with with the attack and
it's just uh the position will very soon
crumble
uh so this is with absolute best defense
for example if something like c3 is
played
but rook captures on f2 seems to be an
even better line
uh but also an insufficient one not not
a better one but it seems more natural
to just
capture the queen and then see what
happens so queen captures on f2 was
played
but now comes g captures on f2 with the
pawn being defended
and now rook to h1 is coming rook to h1
check followed by
just uh queening the pawn so here uh
alireza blocks it with the queen but now
hikaru
instantly plays knight to h5 and
it was in this position on move 17 yes
you've heard me correctly on move 17
that
uh alireza faruja resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
knight g3 is coming and you will not
have any moves you will either have to
give up the queen or move the queen and
then uh
sorry and then black just promotes so
incredible incredible game only 17 moves
but just because it's such a short game
i will show how rich the position is
here alireza resigned because he was uh
down to 15 seconds on the clock and
hikaru was much better on time
but there is one a very poisonous line
uh or poison line
i still haven't decided which one which
one fits better
uh so i will show it uh now of course
knight to g3 is coming but for example
knight to g5 and now of course after
knight to g3 you go knight to e6 check
and it's not all that simple because if
you go king e7 you allow bishop to g5
check and now after king the e8
uh you have knight captures and g7 check
king to d7
uh or you have to go king to f8 and
allow a perpetual
after knight to e6 but if you go here
then this is just checkmate
so one of the possibilities another one
after knight
the e6 check is that you don't go king
to e7 but rather you go king to e8 which
is much better
but then comes knight captures on g7
check and now you have to run with the
king king the 896
czech king to c8 knight captures on c5
and now after knight captures on f1
finally grabbing the queen now bishop to
e6 check and again black has a lot of
options here
to make a mistake not a lot with a lot i
meant one
uh if he goes for example king to d8
king the b8
is the only way uh to uh oh sorry king
the
uh king the b8 uh would be would be uh
uh not winning but it would be much
better for white uh so we're gonna show
this one king b8
now comes knight to d7 with check king
c8 you
have to go uh well here uh
to to suffer some very nasty discoveries
knight captures an e5 with
check king to b8 you're gonna go back
knight captures on c6 with
check b captures and now king to e2 and
the white is
white is actually doing okay because
after rook captures on g2 you can
capture on f1
and after the rook moves uh you're gonna
of course not allow this to come with
check you have two bishops for a rook
and white is perfectly fine here
so the only way for black to win this
after bishop to e6 check is king to uh
d8 and uh now you start going back and
now you allow some checks
bishop to g5 with check king to e8
bishop d7 check team to f7
you're gonna go get king to e2 but now
after rook captures and g2 it's
different
because after the knight on f1 is
captured now you have knight to d4 with
check
uh and uh well the knight here is still
under attack that's the problem king d2
you're gonna get
rook captures on g5 rook captures an f2
with check
king e7 now attacking both the bishop
and the knight here and now it doesn't
matter you're going to lose one of the
pieces let's say knight b3 captures
captures
and now after king captures black is up
a whole rook so in the end
black will prevail but it requires the
absolute best play
and if alireza had a bit more time i'm
sure he would have
tried not to of course find all of this
but
he would have fought and we we would
have uh gotten
a crazy crazy game but this is a
three-minute game so you know it's
pointless to over analyze it i just
showed this line because it's super
interesting
uh but you know of course expecting such
lines to happen in a three-minute blitz
game would be would be completely crazy
so this way it's much better 17 moves a
brilliant miniature
congratulations to hikaru and we we can
only hope that more games such as this
one
uh happen online or over the board
so yeah uh that's uh that's the game i
do hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank uh how to build a rumford
fireplace
john roberts andrew schupik jonathan
starr and kerry
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world such as this
beauty here thank you all i will see you
soon and
have an excellent start of your week